[Música]
olá eu sou melissa l'orange eu sou
formado em letras tem mestrado em
educação tudo aqui na ufrj
eu estou atualmente nessa instituição
como professora substituta e também atua
na rede pública de educação de magé que
para quem não conhece é na região
metropolitana do rio de janeiro
eu sou mãe youtuber completamente flo
adam e se vocês não perceberam eu sou
uma drag queen
sim é uma peruca agora todos vocês já
conhecem o meu currículo é eu estou me
tremendo toda porque né quando você
recebe um convite para palestrar no
teste você venceu na vida como
palestrante então na hora que eu saberei
falou que eu falei quero ainda mais eu
perguntei pra que o que eu ia dizer
nunca façam isso acontece que eu preciso
falar com vocês sobre o conceito de
universidade e unir com o conceito de
drag queen
quando eu descobri isso tudo que eu
pensei foi feita mas acredita que vai
dar certo pega na minha mão que no final
vocês vão entender como esses dois
conceitos se conectam
eu só não coloquei nada ali eu passei
horas máquina então vocês vão ficar
olhando para mim tá bom
muito obrigada então vamos lá vamos
começar entendendo o que é uma drag
queen
não vamos nós não vamos vou se achou que
ia nós não vamos porque drag queen é uma
arte marginal o que significa que cada
artista vai ter a sua própria visão
sobre ser entregue
nós não estamos na bibliografia básica
do curso de história da arte então a
academia não está dando pitaco na nossa
vida
o que eu vou fazer é dizer a minha
posição sobre o que é ser drag para
vocês entenderem o ponto de partida
pra mim drag é uma performance baseada
numa persona que tem como tema o gênero
e esse tema pode ser usado de várias
formas atraente pode burlar o gênero
alterar o gênero inverter o gênero
caracterizar o gênero e reforçar o
gênero o que importa é que ela precisa
pegar esse conceito de gênero e brincar
com ele porque gente o gênero e o sexo
eles são fundamentais na nossa sociedade
para nos definir como seres humanos
eles também definem quais são as
narrativas as quais nós somos permitido
seguir a a gente pode perceber isso em
várias várias várias frases que ouvimos
no dia a dia
por exemplo quando você a quando a
mulher está grávida e ela descobre que é
menina ou até mesmo antes de descobrir
as pessoas já ficam começando a dizer
frases como essa vaga geral ou então aí
minha princesinha vai nascer ou avós ea
mãe da próxima neymar
ninguém pensa em ser a mãe da próxima
para evitar
e também ninguém pensa em ser a mãe da
próxima campeã mundial de judô
e como eu sou professora de redação e
literatura eu acho narrativas muito
muito importante na nossa sociedade
mas quem diz essas coisas não sou eu não
inventei isso é uma sapatão maravilhosa
chamada judith butler que tem um grupo
de reitores aqui no brasil mas isso não
importa
ela disse que o nosso gênero eo nosso
sexo determinam como as pessoas vão
autorizar a nossa existência
para vocês terem uma idéia de como o
gênero definir qualquer coisa qualquer
coisa eu não consigo comprar uma
televisão pela internet sem dizer se eu
sou homem ou mulher porque existe um
quadro escrito sexo no cadastro que é
obrigatório eu preciso marcar ele assim
como o obrigatório que eu determinei o
meu gênero em qualquer rede social por
mais que ela dê várias opções pra gênero
que não sejam só masculino e feminino
porque a partir desta definição que
essas instituições e as outras pessoas
vão saber o que elas podem nos ofertar
como cultura e como consumo e é assim
que elas vão poder nos ver
antes mesmo de a gente dizer alguma
coisa
já tem aquela historinha pré determinada
do que é ser um homem do que é ser uma
mulher
então pensando nisso é muito muito
importante a figura da andretti green
é muito importante que mulheres homens e
pessoas não minar as façam drag porque é
um grande chega pra lá pra esse discurso
que fica determinando o tempo inteiro o
que nós podemos ou não podemos fazer
a drag queen ela não muda de gênero
quando ela se monta
ela só mostra o que já está montado para
a gente aceitar como viável em ser homem
com ser mulher e ela coloca em xeque
essa figura do homem e da mulher
ela mostra que a beleza do homem ea
beleza do corpo da mulher pode ser
completamente burlado e estranhado com
um pouco de produtos cosméticos plástico
algodão e espuma e colocar o gênero em
dúvida é algo fundamental porque se nós
estamos tentando repensar a nossa
sociedade que não está lá muito bacana a
gente tem que começar a pensar em todas
as suas estruturas que entendemos que
são e em na palavras nos meus vídeos
pela internet eu costumo falar sobre
tragédias sem saber que são tragédias
não tem problema explica a professora é
tragédia de acordo com a história diz
carmona grega diz ele diz que as
tragédias são narrativas de grandes
heróis efeitos cujas habilidades são
inalcançáveis e que vão cair em desgraça
através de um teste porque eles são
humanos e que um ano faz desgraça nos
meus vídeos eu costumo dizer que
conceitos idéias instituições e
estruturas culturais também podem ser
tragédias
o que significa que a gente coloca hoje
no ano no topo das nossas prioridades
como se elas fossem estáveis e seguras
mas é só a gente esperar um pouquinho
para olhar de perto e ver que elas podem
sim cair em desgraça
o gênero é uma dessas tragédias porque
não sei quando a drag queen bota uma
roupa piro
a maquiagem já fica um tá no palco
cantando a gente já mostra que é bem
frágil essa idéia do gênero
o gene afeta a vida da gente diretamente
mas é como um tanque de vidro
ele causa um enorme estrago mas qualquer
coisinha já faz é de lascar
agora não é mais a e aí o que eu quero
aqui é mostrar que você pode me
perguntar por exemplo agora sim estou
falando aos oito minutos e me perguntar
melissa e ramiro e melissa e o que está
a ver com a universidade que não
entendendo se quer chegar
calma que eu falo muito que eu sou muito
tempo rasca mas a gente vai jogar fé
café
vamos chegar lá para isso vai contar uma
história a contar uma história que isso
é muito importante não deve contar uma
história que vou contar uma história de
quando eu falei para os meus alunos e
alunas que são futuros professores e
professoras de língua portuguesa e
perguntei gente
qual a função da educação de acordo com
a ldb lei de diretrizes e bases da
educação
ninguém sabia porque a gente ignora nbb
como se ela não fosse lê tudo bem não
vamos entrar nesses pormenores
o texto da lei diz que a função da
educação é o pleno desenvolvimento do
educando o seu preparo para o exercício
da cidadania e para o mundo do trabalho
aonde está escrito identificar orações
subordinadas substantivas e onde está
escrito que tem que saber fazer uma
equação de segundo grau não sei mas eu
quero que todo mundo aqui pare e pense
agora acesso à educação escolar dos seis
aos 17 em média ajudou vocês a se
formarem ou chegou à conclusão do
objetivo de que você se formassem
plenamente como o sujeito para exercer
cidadania para o mundo do trabalho
se alguém levantou a mão essa pessoa por
favor depois me explica como ela
conseguiu isso porque eu tô aqui com
mais de 30 anos neste palco eu ainda
estou em plena formação do meu caráter e
da minha cidadania mas
eu posso dizer que a escola de fato foi
uma instituição que me ajudou bastante a
desenvolver a minha cidadania porque ela
é mais do que só um lugar próprio de
orações subordinadas ou equações do
segundo grau muito bem e se você pensar
bem o universitário entra na faculdade
entre a universidade saindo da escola
como um velho adulto e entrando aqui
como num ele sai da escola e entra aqui
como um velho adolescente né e até aqui
como um jovem adulto muito bem e aí
agora você pára olha para a sua fileira
identifique o universitário por favor do
adversário porque levanta a mão para
ajudar no exemplo olha para o lado e eu
não tô vendo vocês porque tava na minha
cara eu estou acreditando que estou
fazendo tudo tá
olha essa pessoa e pensa está plenamente
formado em alguma circunstância vai né
e aí que entra a universidade a
universidade tem que lembrar que o seu
novo calouro não chegou aqui formado
plenamente a universidade tem que
continuar o processo de formação para a
cidadania deste indivíduo desse sujeito
dessa criatura de deus e ela faz isso
não sei o que eu sei é que assim como o
gênero a universidade também tem várias
e várias narrativas pré-determinadas que
a gente tenta seguir o que na verdade é
muito difícil por exemplo alguém que se
formou no tempo regular da universidade
pode se retirar por favor que eu só
aceito que está atrasado já que vou
cobrir as parras após que eu falo muito
bacana o tempo vamos lá mas no final deu
tudo certo
a universidade tem que lembrar que ela
tem esse trabalho de continuar a
formação mas a gente ouvir tantas
histórias por exemplo é a universidade
se tornou atualmente o destino natural
dos bons alunos da escola e isso é um
preço muito alto para se pagar porque
como é que a escola vai formar
plenamente 8
qando série está formando plenamente o
vestibulando não tem como desenvolver a
cidadania de uma pessoa se eu estou
preocupado nesta pessoa fazer uma prova
fica muito difícil juntar as duas coisas
e na verdade o vestibular e todo esse
processo é uma falácia é uma maldade eu
costumo dizer que quando vocês passam
entre vocês acreditem que passa em
primeiro lugar no vestibular para
medicina engenharia direito qualquer
coisa
isso quer dizer apenas que vocês se
classificaram em primeiro lugar no
processo seletivo
só porque você vai fazer a disciplina
junto com um cara que está na terceira
reclassificação que vai acompanhar você
na faculdade toda a maldade que fizeram
você estudar o tempo que perdeu da sua
adolescência tempo já fazendo besteira
você não vai preso direito então esse
tempo você perdeu estudando morre no
primeiro período que ninguém liga
se você passar o 1º ou se você foi
reclassificado ninguém pergunta para
você então é uma maldade é uma falácia
uma coisa que sustenta um sistema que
não funciona muito bem mas isso só o
prólogo que tem o primeiro capítulo né
a pessoa chega aqui e já fala e foi mal
a mim é federal
se você falou isso não levanta o braço
que vai ficar muito bravo
isso é um absurdo o primeiro que a sua
não é federal a nossa tem que ter muito
muito trabalho para manter a
universidade federal funcionando e muita
luta e só quando a coisa se você
acredita que você chegou aqui sozinho ou
sozinha pare imediatamente de passar
vergonha por que você não chegou aqui
sozinho você teve uma rede enorme de
afectos e depois para conseguir chegar
aqui e talvez quando você fala isso para
ofender o universidade da rede privada
você não entenda que este universitário
não teve o mesmo apoio que você e que
talvez ele tenha esperado coisas muito
mais difíceis do que você esperou para
estar ali na rede privada
e vou dizer mais para você estar aqui na
rede pública ele precisa estar lá na
rede privada porque na nossa sociedade
para alguém conseguir alguma coisa ou
outra pessoa não pode conseguir
existem várias outras falácias que a
gente escuta tem uma que me incomoda
bastante que é de barras entre
universidade e aí você consegue um bom
emprego um bom salário
eu sou professora estou esperando o bom
salário
eu não gosto nem de falar muito não
poder imprimir e eu não quero falar
sobre isso quer da autoridade preço
argumenta que é mais falso que os meus
peitos
mas a gente fica repetindo isso
constantemente porque na adolescência já
está no universo de incertezas qualquer
toco de madeira essa garra né a não vou
ter um bom emprego
a questão é que o adolescente não tem
que saber disso cara tentando o calor
não tem que saber se quem sabe disso
somos nós a comunidade universitária os
veteranos e os professores
universitários porque esse cara não está
plenamente informado
e aí eu te pergunto é essa universidade
que a gente encontra a universidade ela
tem que lembrar que ela não é uma
fábrica de produção em massa de
trabalhadores com bons empregos bem
sucedidos que depois de ter um emprego
bem sucedido vai defender nas redes
sociais e na rua ações de fim de
democracia com a camisa da ufrj a
universidade tem que entender lembrar
que ela não pode se vender por fomento
de pesquisa
ela também tem que lembrar que aqui
dentro são feitas diversas
discriminações em seu nome e que as
maiores atrocidades são ditas por causa
desse status da universidade federal
quando ela permite isso ela se torna
parte da máquina de moer gente que nós
chamamos de status corpo e não parece em
nada com o lugar que vai produzir
ciência e educação
então eu queria juntar num
[Música]
[Aplausos]
obrigado
então eu queria juntar os conceitos de
gênero em universidade e fazer aqui uma
exposição numa vida e à eu gostaria que
a universidade olhar sobre seu espaço e
por conhecimento universitário como nós
drag queen se olhamos para o gênero como
algo frágil e que não serve para todo
mundo e porque não serve para todo mundo
deve ser questionado
a universidade tem que parar de pensar
na beleza das coisas e se tornar mais
incômoda e que ela seja incômoda como
nós drag queens na nossa figura somos
encomendas mas que ela também seja
encantadora como tenho absoluta certeza
que estou encantando todos vocês
obrigada é espuma
uma coisa é meu peito mas há nada de
verdade tudo uma grande mentira de
evangelismo
mas vamos lá né a gente tem que pensar
que a universidade e universitário
precisam rever os seus status por
exemplo o adversário tem que parar de
achar que vai seguir essa roteirinho
sessão da tarde sabe essa tragédia que
alguém escreveu pra gente porque os
roteiristas meu amor estão loucos
eles não sabem o que estão fazendo
talvez quando nós escrevemos na nossa
própria história não em tragédia mas em
sátira à vida fique mais leve que a
universidade possa ter um pouco de
autocrítica para que ela possa se
aproximar do objetivo da educação básica
que a formar plenamente os cidadãos para
o exercício da cidadania e não só para o
mundo do trabalho
bom era só isso que eu queria dizer eu
estou muito feliz vocês terem escutado
se vocês me permitirem então vocês burle
obrigada
[Aplausos]
[Música]